all right we are wrapping up 2016 by
looking at some of the most whatever
videos on YouTube of 2016 let's look at
the five most commented videos on our
YouTube channel these are new clips from
2016 we'll start the countdown with
number five video number five Sarah
Palin loses it when asked about blaming
Obama for his her son beating his
girlfriend nearly a million views but
importantly for our discussion here
nearly three thousand comments the
fourth most commented video on YouTube
of 2016 Donald Trump accused of raping
13-year old girl in federal lawsuit
nearly five thousand individual comments
on that video from 2016 are you wearing
an Argentina Jersey I'm wearing an
Argentina Jersey in this because it was
during the America Cup and I was
bringing my team spirit to the show
absolutely the third most commented
video of 2016
Trump forgets cameras exist says black
people are uneducated poor and jobless
over five thousand comments on that
video on YouTube from August of 2016
number two the second most commented
video the blistering expose of reza
aslan called reza aslan cannot be
trusted from january of 2016
nearly seventy five hundred comments
during 2016 and lastly the number one
most commented video of 2016 from the
david pakman show youtube channel is
embarrassing trump audio exposes him as
totally clueless and we can just barely
see due to my fault the number of
comments but it is over nine thousand
comments nearly ten thousand comments on
this video during 2016 this is the video
that rush limbaugh commented on and made
fun of me for and i think i wear that as
a badge of honor the five most commented
videos on our youtube channel please
make sure you're subscribed to our
youtube channel so that we can have an
even bigger 2017 than the 2016 that we
had